je crois je les ai soutenus je pense
qu'il a su montrer sa capacité à
rassembler les socialistes à se situer
au coeur du ps est aujourd'hui tout
commence pour lui
donc je pense que nous ouvrons une
nouvelle phase tout commence mais ça va
être difficile on a vu olivier faur la
semaine dernière il ya quelques jours
dans les cortèges syndicaux en ti sncf
se faire siffler le ps n'est plus en
odeur de sainteté
justement dans ce type de courtage c'est
un problème bien sûr que ce sera
difficile mais ça c'est pas le principal
problème y compris quand le ps était en
bonne santé électorale
il y avait toujours un qui ne trouvait
pas assez à gauche et qui nous siffler
dans les cortèges nous sortons de cinq
années de responsabilité gouvernementale
moi j'étais heureux qu'olivier fort et
de nombreux socialistes participent à
ces manifestations
et nous allons continuer lorsque nous
pensons que notre présence est
nécessaire et je crois que ça va être le
cas parce qu'il y avait à la fois
beaucoup d'injustice sociale
et puis très peu de prise en compte des
services publics aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement au delà
ceci dit notre participation aux
manifestations
il faut qu olivier faur engage un
travail du parti socialiste pour
reconstruire un projet et je sais que
c'est sa volonté sur la question de la
ligne justement il ya eu un autre coup
dur c'est le départ d'une partie de la
direction du mjs vers le mouvement
génération de benoît hamon c'est une
scission historique - salle ps au moins
ça clarifie les choses
il était un certain nombre à être humble
non enfin viennent venait de se faire
hier à tête du moins des jeunes
socialistes alors qu'ils étaient déjà
passés en réalité à génération le parti
socialiste a besoin d'un mouvement de
jeunesse qui soit peut être autonome et
j'ai été au moins des jeunes socialistes
ya quelques il ya quelques années mais
qu'ils soient proches et solidaires et
qui travaille avec le parti socialiste
donc ça clarifie les choses
par ailleurs comme l'ancienne présidente
du mjs est parti avec des mots très
maladroit
qui montre une forme d'arrogance de
mépris en l'occurrence pour les nos
aînés voilà je pense que d'ailleurs cet
esprit d'arrogance
c'est ce qui doit absolument quitter le
parti socialiste donc chacun fait ses
choix bon vent